i was so pure and they took that away
from me i felt like because
from then on after i got the plastic
surgery consultant
after living in korea and being
constantly criticized for everything
that i
am i started to doubt myself a lot
in anything that i do and i was very um
i just had no self-esteem for
any creative choices any life choices
anything like uh even the way i looked i
just was constantly just
insecure about everything you know in
five
four three two one what's up everybody
welcome to another episode of the genius
brain podcast we have a very special
guest today you know
usually when we do these podcasts i i
always bring in like a couple of
set regulars but i actually haven't seen
this young lady
in the longest [ __ ] time and you're
so grown
you're such a big ass girl now dude life
happens
we have megan lee dude how are you i'm
doing
great i mean you know surviving like
everyone else when you
when i first met you did you you just
you were on youtube first or were you
on the music scene in the music scene
first um i was on youtube first i
started my channel when i was 13 years
old
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah 13 years ago even when
i think about i'm like
damn i was crazy what year was that what
year is that when you were 13. uh
so that was like 11 years ago
so do i do yeah 2009.
that's [ __ ] nuts yeah you started you
actually started youtube before i did
which is [ __ ] crazy oh did i really
yeah oh my god then you started a year
before i did
i wasn't like super active until i was
like 14 15 though
he's so [ __ ] young i wasn't super
active until i was 14
14 15. that's so [ __ ] funny 15 though
i'm 24. [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah you a big ass
girl did you did you go to college and
everything
i didn't go to college well i took like
college now
i mean i do i still have it at the back
of my head um
i i do wish to have time to go back to
college
but the thing is that like i don't know
exactly what i would want to study
i don't want to study music i don't want
to study acting or film
i want to do something that's completely
different um and that i would have
a lot of passion for i mean if you don't
know what you want to go to college
don't go to college exactly that's why
i'm like it's a lot of it's a lot of
money it's a lot of time and dedication
and i just don't want to
like have added stress
you missed out on a on us an experience
from not going to college because i feel
like that's a lot of people
i didn't go to high school either i was
homeschooled because damn you didn't go
to high school either no
girl you ain't being bullied for a very
interesting life i think i can say
um because i started being exposed to
like
the public at a very young age so like i
i
started acting when i was 10 years old
and i did a lot of commercials i was
always like on like local tv
and like kids at school recognized me i
got made fun of it for it
actually a lot but kids are so [ __ ]
mean dude
i saw you in a kid's pop commercial um
but uh
and then i just like i love music so i
wanted to like express myself and i
discovered youtube and all of like
our favorite youtube artists from back
in the day like the asian american
community and
i got inspired to like make my own
videos and kind of got started through
there
whose choice was it for you to go to go
through homeschool was that something
that you wanted or your parents wanted
um it was kind of both because
while i was acting i started getting
more
i started getting busier towards like 15
16 years old going into high school
yeah and i realized that my local high
school uh they were very strict because
they were a charter school
uh they were strict on attendance so
knowing that i missed school a lot
especially during middle school
yeah it's just not acceptable they're
going to give me automatic fs
if i miss a certain amount of classes i
thought they would do the thing where
you get to
take your work somewhere else like if
you have they did have a program called
independent studies
so i did that for a year and then i
moved to korea
so yeah i moved to korea uh
like towards the last the first year the
end of the first year of high school
and i became homeschooled since then
that's [ __ ] nuts man like i
i feel like a big part of me growing up
like
even though i don't remember everything
from high school high school was a huge
part of me that helped
molded who i was today right in terms of
adversity dealing with like social
awkwardness you know
that that weird love face that dating
phase liking the girl in high school
that you're kind of
scared to meet up and talk to and stuff
i mean for you i mean that's that's
something that you were exempt from
right
so i mean how does that work for you
then like when you were i mean when
you're in that ages age from what 14 all
the way till 18 right yeah how does the
dating experience happen for you it was
non-existent
i didn't really date i didn't date at
all actually in high school
um during that year during those years
really because i moved to korea i did a
little singing competition show i don't
know if you knew about
that but i did that and i got signed to
a label and so i lived there for four
years so all throughout my high school
years i was in korea
and i i don't in some ways i feel like i
didn't really miss out that much from
high school because i
feel like i kind of got like punched in
the face with
life in general out of like very fast
all at once that's it
that's that's the difference though is
like high school is where you're you're
allowed to be a kid
and so i think for you you were kind of
forced up forced to be a grown up so
[ __ ] fast yeah you know
i had my moments where i was still able
to have fun
because at the end of the day like i
knew that's that's what i wanted i knew
that i wanted it was great yeah yeah
i wanted i wanted to be a singer i want
to be an entertainer like whatever it
took
for me to like do what i love to do and
at that time it was to go to korea and
like be
seeing her there what was the show that
you were on it was called within tensing
which translates to great great birth of
a star
uh in korean is that like american idol
it was like more like the voice because
they had like mentorship
oh yeah who's your mentor uh
oh really damn that's looking crazy dude
when that
does that make you super nervous yeah oh
hella
like and the worst part was that i
sucked at korean
i didn't speak a leak lick of korean my
pronunciation was trash yeah i sounded
like like a whitewashed person
for sure i yeah i was constantly
criticized for
not being able to speak korean well so
that was like a really big
uh stress for me living in korea like a
huge culture
criticized by your peers or was it
criticized just by korean people in
korea in general
in general yeah in the media and also
like on set like by the taka like the
the writers producers uh staff on the
show they would always be like
megan you have to practice your korean
war but like
yeah i mean it's a thing in asia where
like they expect you to like oh a
hundred percent
it's funny because uh i only know
of this because of korean people that
come to the united states and they judge
you right and i'm like [ __ ] you're in
[ __ ] america [ __ ] i'm judging you
like the [ __ ] which is so odd like i
never understood why
specifically like in korea they're so
particular about it
like they like to see they're very
judgmental very judgmental especially
with like
they [ __ ] don't like the fact that
you can't speak the language even though
they know your backstory they go
you could tell them like bro i was born
in the united states
and it's like for them that would be
like me saying like well you came to the
united states when you were [ __ ]
i don't know 15 years old and you can't
speak english and i should [ __ ] on you
for that
yeah you know which is a very odd thing
it is
um and so dealing with that was
definitely stressful living there
a lot of cultural shock a lot of
language barriers it was really hard for
me to really express
myself i feel like um
those years to me are actually very
vivid um
like like how you were saying um you
don't really remember your high school
years for me like
it's it was so impactful that like till
this day like i still remember
a lot of details of like my experiences
being in korea
and just like being a teenager there um
and it's because like
i felt like i didn't have a voice like i
was constantly like i'm naturally a
people pleaser
and like being in korea like there is
that like hierarchy
like respecting yourself that's good in
korea like people like people pleasers
in korea they like
they like the hierarchy of the younger
person you know
respecting the older person see i knew
that it benefited me because i knew that
like oh i just have to be tuck kid i
have to be a good person all people hate
me in korea dude
problematic but the thing is that i lost
my voice like i felt like i didn't
deserve to have an opinion
i couldn't speak out um i couldn't make
even creative decisions on my own like
when i was on the show specifically they
didn't allow me to sing
uh an english song because i don't yeah
i don't know why
um but they had other korean
singers korean-american singers too that
uh sing english songs and i really
wanted to sing an english song to really
showcase like my style and the type of
music that i like to sing
and i really love r b uh pop soul
music and i really wanted what really
wanted to sing a christy aguilera song
yeah and they didn't let me and
uh they would just give me like songs
that i've never heard of before
and just make me sing it on the spot and
just like purposely try to like
i don't know like embarrass me because i
couldn't speak korean
you know it's so fascinating when i hear
that because i had another friend who
was
on a a korean show as well
right she probably doesn't want me to
say her name so i won't say her name but
she
she did one of these contestant shows
right and she spoke
i have yet to meet somebody who has been
on one of those korean shows that talked
about a good experience
and it's it's you know at first it's
like true
it's like first it's kind of like okay
maybe it's just one person but one is
about two three or four people now and
they say the same things
it makes me wonder what goes on in this
industry right now and especially
specifically how
you know the korean war culture is and
how they treat
people who are quote-unquote
subordinates now there's a lot of korean
people who listen to this in korea and
you know they have a lot of korean pride
and they might come out and defend this
i'm talking about personal stories so
you can go [ __ ] and die for all i care
but this is
this is really no because there's always
like some kind of [ __ ] them to the show
there's always some kind of [ __ ] out
there they go well you never
i'm not talking about my experience i'm
talking about with these people i've had
one-on-one conversations with them yeah
about people who have been in this
industry and this is how it is for any
kind of entertainment industry but
specifically in korea seems really harsh
yeah like after she was done with uh
being a contestant on the show
she she spoke of how they they kind of
just
tossed her off like she was garbage like
after she was done they didn't
number one she doesn't speak any korean
at all you know and
she doesn't know how to get around the
only relative that she had in korea was
her grandmother
and so she was there and they're like
okay i think i know who you're talking
about you kicked off the show and they
just left her off in the middle of the
street and that was it
that happens like what the [ __ ] is that
like the fact that they couldn't even
treat her like a respectable human being
is the most aggravating thing
and uh even with her i've you know i've
heard other stories of another girl who
very talented musician and she was
scouted and they loved her music they
loved her style she definitely had some
stuff that people in korea didn't have
and she had a lot to offer
yeah but they wanted her to get surgery
to change certain things about her face
and she said no so they said
we're good you know what i mean like how
the [ __ ] and it seems to happen
a lot to women oh specifically with
these types of shows like and that's
what i've
i've seen the bias i seen like
the discrimination i definitely felt the
discrimination like i saw
other peers who were in my position
korean american didn't really know how
to speak korean well
but they were male and they were always
more favored
by the staff on the shows and to me
they'd be like
to another guy that speaks probably
worse korean than i do
they'll be like oh my god you're so cute
oh haha you're so funny
uh it's so charming that you don't speak
korean well it's okay you'll learn
and then to me like you piece of [ __ ]
because um just another personal story
i'm not gonna say
well actually you know mario will will
speak about this on a podcast maybe when
she comes on later but she
my fiance spoke about not not so much in
uh korean culture
but in japanese culture too it's also
like that as well specifically how they
speak to and treat women in the company
yeah right she she told me of this
really quick story i'm just going to
paraphrase it where essentially
you know she worked for a japanese
a company that came to america and it
was a food company was a food
conglomerate right
and she is like the liaison for american
culture
and so her opinion really does matter
especially when it comes to the
workspace and how they treat employees
so you know she was she kind of said her
opinion about you know how things
go go about here and one of the male
guys looked at her and
basically straight up said to her in
japanese like you're a woman why are you
even talking
you know what i mean like that's that's
the type of stuff
that you know and i feel like those are
the similarities the very bad
similarities in japanese and korean work
culture that happens a lot
yeah and it's weird because they're
they're kind of bringing you on and you
guys are singing like american songs and
[ __ ] and they they know that you're from
america but
yeah i think nowadays uh
in the recent years it has gotten a
little better
from what i hear and what i see in the
media
but it's they're they're still so behind
when it comes to
uh the change in like their the work
culture in general was it was it hard
for you
specifically because you were so young
right yeah it was very confusing i just
didn't know how to react i just know
that i felt horrible about it
and i the worst part was like at the
time like
i thought it deserved to feel horrible
like
you know what i mean it was i just
didn't know how to react exactly so kind
of like how they made you feel you felt
like that was it was your fault
yeah and so i constantly felt like i had
to like better myself that was actually
my motivation so i actually did learn
korean
i speak reasonably well
like conversationally yeah um
but it it took a lot of like blood sweat
and tears because of the constant
criticizing
i think i could have spoke even better
korean if they were like really nice
about it and more encouraging
yeah but because they're just so bashing
i'm just like crying and i want
for me i guess i had a pretty this
podcast is brought to you by purple my
friends
have you been sleeping on a piece of
turd your whole life i guarantee you
have not been sleeping on a purple
mattress
let alone any purple product because
their products are
absolutely amazing if you've ever
received
a purple product before you already know
about the technology you already know
about
that mesh integrated cooling stuff that
rocket science technology that was
developed
to keep you comfortable i've had the
worst sleeps of my life
until i met up with my purple the purple
technology and this stuff is really
really crazy especially for somebody
like me who has been sleeping on really
really hard beds and on top of that
i get really hot and the purple
technology keeps me super cool so
kudos to that well my friends experience
the purple grid and you'll sleep like
never before go to purple.com
gb10 and use promo code gb10 for a
limited time you'll get 10
off any order of 200 or more that's
purple.com gb10
promo code gb10 for 10 off any order of
200
or more terms apply tough skin i guess
for a 15 year old so i just like i took
it
and i used it as fuel to just
learn freaking learning curriculum i
just tell them i'm chinese
i'm chinese this is what you get this is
pretty good for a [ __ ] chinese guy
that's what i do if i go to korea
somebody gives me [ __ ] about my [ __ ]
korean i'm slapping them in the [ __ ]
face
also my motivation was like i knew that
i wanted to be a singer in korea and so
like i knew like if i'm going to be a
singer here i'm going to have to learn
the language anyway so it's just like
knew that it was like a price to pay
just gotta pay my dues and stuff who's
like the one that's kind of
i mean when i see you as a 14 or 15 year
old girl and you're in korea you're
going through all these emotions
specifically
a lot of self-esteem issues because of
how these people are talking to you
specifically as a young woman out there
um who's like the one that's in your
corner then that's kind of giving you
a lot of good advice is helping you and
supporting you mom oh your mom was out
there with you yeah oh that's
i don't think i would have survived if
my mom wasn't there that's great yeah so
i was
really really lucky like i've heard
other stories from like people my age
who were out in korea trying to pursue
music there as well
and they didn't have their parents they
didn't have like a family member to be
their moral support
and it's it's freaking hard you know
being that young
to be out there and be so like
bashed and criticized and like have life
thrown at you all at once
um i was i was able to survive because
of my mom
honestly what kind of what kind of
things were like said to you
specifically like what would they say to
you
everything from like my korean
to the way i sing to uh
my looks everything like pretty much
they just criticize every aspect
of me what would they say about your
looks
um so i did get signed to a label there
and i was like a trainee for two years
and then i debuted
in my label i actually got plastic
surgery consultation
and they just literally drew like a map
of a face and just like drew like dotted
lines
jesus and like she told me like i had to
cut my jaws i had to like
do this to my nose like make my eyes
bigger
all like the typical like beauty
standards that you would expect from
like korean celebrities and um
uh the the total the amount of money
that it would take for me to look a
certain way was just like
it was so big that like my label was
just like okay let's just go all natural
that's [ __ ] ridiculous i was so
scared though actually i did do one
procedure
um they actually removed my mole i had a
small
little i actually really miss it um i
had a small little dot
it looked like a pen mark on my face my
mom really liked it too she was like
it's it's like
like a little charm yeah i had one here
and one here yeah
and if you look at my old pictures like
it's gone it's there but
now it's it's gone so that's kind of
crazy man
i mean it's so weird that they would do
that to somebody so young and they would
ask you to change your face
especially when you're when you you
you're barely a [ __ ] adult you're not
even an adult yet
yeah and that's something that you
honestly straight up
there are some people out some women out
there and even boys right but i'll say
for girls there are some girls out there
at your age when you're like 14 or 15
you guys haven't even grown to your
[ __ ] face yet no you don't even
you don't even know what you're going to
look like later very slow growing i
realized like
you haven't changed one bit you look you
went into a time capsule
and you just stayed in there the whole
time so when you when you got this page
and they're like telling you this is
what you have to change in your body
how did that make you feel i i cried i
cried for a good week i felt so ugly
um from then on i just i i was actually
a very
confident kid i guess you could say i
was blissfully ignorant
i was that kid that like i don't know if
you remember but like
i wore like the craziest outfits i had
like knee-high socks i had like rainbows
on them like i was literally like an
asian jojo
you know what i'm talking about but like
not as
not as excessive but like i was like an
asian jojo like i just like i didn't
give an f like i wore whatever the heck
i want i was like super bubbly
i still am but um i just was so
i was so pure and they took that away
from me i felt like because
from then on after i got the plastic
surgery consultant
after living in korea and being
constantly criticized for everything
that i
am i started to doubt myself a lot
in anything that i do it i was very um i
just had no self-esteem for
any creative choices any life choices
anything like uh even the way i looked i
just was constantly just
insecure about everything you know when
i
when i have a conversation with um i i
didn't grow up with a lot of korean
people
so i i don't know technically like
my korean-american experience is simply
from my outlook from
my family that's really about it and
what i'm finding out is that my family
is actually
very very odd like they don't they're
not very typically
korean they don't my mom doesn't really
judge the way that i look the way that i
act or behave she just always wanted me
to be happy
that's just so sweet it's not very
korean from what i'm hearing from other
people yeah the only
hardcore korean thing was my dad he
wanted me to be a doctor lawyer
businessman okay
that's really about it he was the
hardcore typical korean dad my dad was
like that too
yeah my mom was like your mom yeah which
is very nice to have that that was the
the great balance of things it's kind of
hard like listening to you when you're
when you're that young too you're super
impressionable and you have a young
child that's super bright that wants to
do things
and then you just tell them that they
can't do anything and it's like how can
you take that away from somebody who's
supposed to be like your star
like you're supposed to build these
these young people up and when i
you know i told i tell these stories
before all the time right specifically
on this podcast
and every [ __ ] k-pop stand comes at
me they're like what the [ __ ] do you
know it's like [ __ ] i'm in [ __ ]
entertainment
i know more about this [ __ ] than you
ever [ __ ] will you're on the outside
and you're
listening to this [ __ ] but we're talking
about real life stories from people that
i have met
you know and your story too is very
congruent with a lot of these young
k-pop stars that i've met
and they talk about their experiences
and you know yeah well i always wonder
too
you know when when people go into these
situations do people understand the the
trade-off that you get
you know you lose when a label takes
over right and this is not
just in korea too this is like music in
general you you essentially become their
product
like and they want their product to be
exactly the way that they want it
essentially that's what it is yeah and
if you deviate from that they're like
well we're not getting what we asked for
in this product and they get hyper
disappointed yeah which the the hard and
sad part about that is that you kind of
you lose your human aspect it's like
well where's my voice
this is really an art and so when i say
when i say to people
when she's talking about her surgery
situation and i say this and you guys
get mad when i say
every one of these [ __ ] girls look
exactly the same i
i'm not saying it as a diss it's a
[ __ ] fact you know they go to the
same [ __ ] circle there's only one
kind of beauty standard in korea it's
not like
all shapes and sizes it's not like that
over there at least
not yet i mean it i i feel it's it's
weird because i'm watching like k-pop
now and i remember
the uh specifically in asia the the
thigh gap thing was huge
oh my god and now the
the more curvaceous women are coming out
and now that that's starting to be a
little
popularized right showing a little you
know what's so weird i saw
a k-pop video music video and they were
[ __ ] like
making out in that [ __ ] which really
which one i can't remember i was
at a restaurant and it was it was very
odd it was very sexualized
and i don't you don't really usually see
that yeah it's still
pretty conservative over there yeah
relatively i mean the the production
value in their music video is [ __ ]
insane
yeah i think that's where like korean
entertainment's really [ __ ] good
they thrive in that aspect for sure what
was your uh when did you debut
uh when did i debut i think it was
2011. how did that feel
for you um especially because you went
through all this [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know what's so sad i that like my
goal was to ultimately debut
and i was like working so hard and
paying my dues
to that moment and then when i did
it didn't feel good really no why i mean
it felt like a relief
that like yay i debuted but
at the time like more [ __ ] was going
down in the company
i don't want to talk too much about the
details yeah but
uh it was like everything was just so
hyperactive
negatively in within behind the scenes
that it drove me to file lawsuit against
my company
to leave oh wow yeah and so
that's the biggest reason why i was like
unhappy
also because i was going through vocal
issues so that's actually
um one of the biggest things that like
has an impact
to me today even um
when i see vocal notes uh-huh i'd start
developing vocal noises oh [ __ ]
yeah and i still struggle with it today
and so that's why like music is like
it's it's yeah it's it's a very
complicated thing for me i mean if
they're if they have these people
training you and [ __ ] like
weren't they wary of that [ __ ] like
vocal notes are serious [ __ ]
they literally there's this is one
person in the company that was telling
me that i have to sing until like my
my throat bleeds that's [ __ ] nice i
was singing for hours and hours to the
point it became like
really unhealthy and i wasn't sleeping i
wasn't eating correctly either
like i was literally eating like half a
sweet potato
some cherry tomatoes and
a small piece of tofu and that's it you
know what's so nuts too when i hear
stuff like that
there are so they put so much idea and
thought into
you know whatever the image of these
korean pop stars right
yeah you can't [ __ ] hire a [ __ ]
nutritionist
like there's a science to this
specifically when it comes to people
losing weight and being fit
there's a sciences including including
rest active rest
off days and as a vocal teacher they
should know that too
like you can't make somebody crazy thing
is that like
the person that well there's people in
the company that would give me these
like diets
but also this was recommended by like i
had a personal
uh trainer okay and they would give me
this kind of diet
as well is he a dumb [ __ ] like
like like there's i because i've you
know i lost like a sizeable amount of
weight and so
these nutritionists they understand i
mean is it because they want you to lose
weight faster
or what like what are they going for i
don't understand yeah faster
yeah they a lot of koreans kind of do
that like
like a lot of weight loss in a really
short amount of time
and um which is an odd thing because
they're you're training for what a
couple of
years right i mean you could get
whatever ideal body that they want in
terms of fitness in two years
is a perfect amount of time it should be
a slow thing
i don't understand that like you have
all this money you can't hire a proper
nutritionist
and a proper nutritionist a dietitian
and a trainer like that's
why the [ __ ] not yeah you know and you
could do it in a healthy way i don't
understand how
a vocal coach can tell you sing until
your [ __ ] throat bleeds when
that's the exact opposite of what you
should do i mean look at people like
celine dion she doesn't even use her
voice
at all if she has a performance that
week she doesn't talk
yeah rest rest rest rest
people don't these are basic concepts
specifically when it comes to singing i
don't understand why they would say that
to you
yeah and i think also at the same time
it was just like a lot of mental
it's trying to break like yeah it was
just like a lot of mental breakdown like
a lot of pressure
and i just didn't know how to
handle everything because it was just
like a lot and i was really young
like how could you handle that [ __ ] yeah
and like i i think also
like again um it was just like the lack
of self-esteem so i wasn't able to
really like
keep myself stable and strong enough to
the point that like it without even
realizing it was
all the stress was attacking my like my
health
and so um at one point right before my
debut
i lost my voice
and i got really sick um i got like
like my entire body was just sick like i
was having like stomach issues
i was throwing up and um also because i
was just like
nutrition deficient yeah and um i lost
my voice as well
and then i got better better i went to
uh the ent because i was starting to
have like
issues with like my singing um that was
very abnormal
and uh i couldn't even sing my debut
song comfortably
and that's obviously an issue so like i
went to the ent and he said like oh
um you have you like you're just like
you're over using your voice just like
get rest i'm like
huh rest yeah sure
yeah don't tell that to my vocal cords
she told me to sing like
yeah it's a joke right um and
i just kind of like i don't know i
didn't really think much of it i
really regret that so much i wish like i
was
even more vocal again and
more adamant about my health but you
couldn't be though
because at that point they're grooming
you to obey and when you're that young
and they break you down systematically
continuously every day
you lose your voice like you did you
know you know physically and
metaphorically
right yeah so you know you as a 14 or 15
year old
there's absolutely no way that would
have happened i mean even for me as a
four i was a very defiant child but if
somebody's growing me to be
an obedient pet it would be hard for me
to break out of that [ __ ] too
you know not everybody's gonna be that
you know people a lot of people like to
talk about personal responsibility but
there's personal responsibility and
there's also the reason why
people do what they do at a certain
point right so what i mean by that is
that
a lot of people can tell you well you
should have just spoke up but you
weren't in that situation
you don't know what led to me being in
that mental state where i couldn't speak
up
so for you as a 14 or 15 year old i this
podcast is brought to you by better help
is there something interfering with your
happiness or is preventing you from
achieving your goals
maybe you realize that your mental
health needs a boost or is just
something you haven't really focused on
in your life
i personally have done online counseling
and therapy and it's been great mental
health has been a huge focus in my life
especially the past year and it's
something that i believe that people
should tend to
on a consistent basis better help is
great because they can match you with
your own professional license therapist
you can schedule your sessions via phone
communicate and message online video
calls
and you can even change your counselors
if needed if you want to give this a try
of course for my genius brain listeners
i got the hookup for you to get 10
off your first month of betterhelp just
type in
betterhelp.com genius to get that
offer today once again that's
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p-com
genius to get 10 off your first month of
better help
to a better you i wouldn't even made it
that far i'll just be like [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you i wish i had that energy
honestly i was just i wouldn't have gone
anywhere though
but like but that you're protecting
yourself but i was such an enabler
and there's definitely i mean it's perks
because
you know you're paying your dues and
you'll get to where you want to be but
at the end of the day like
it destroys you and i really do feel
like that
i feel that impact today like i deal
with a condition called
mtd muscle tension dysphonia and
it has developed over the years what's
empty what is it exactly
so basically it's a condition where your
throat
uh would tense up a lot like the muscles
around like your vocal cords would tense
up a lot like you know when you're
nervous or like yes
yeah like vocal fry like all that stuff
like eventually at some point like
you i i kind of like forgot how to sing
these days i don't sing life
because it physically hurts yeah to sing
and um it hasn't always been that way
from the beginning
it's just slowly developed over time and
a lot of is also affected by my mental
health as well
oh so it's a psychological issue psycho
a psychological
but also i had notes as well yeah and i
just like
i was just so unaware of it that's crazy
so for people who don't know vocal noses
are those are like that's the the
death call for singers right and so you
know a lot of people think that you can
just get surgery from it well there's a
very high chance that after you get uh
surgery for vocal nodes that it can
change your voice forever
like it'll it'll [ __ ] up your voice yeah
so for example
uh mariah carey she had ridiculous uh
vocal notes and you guys have heard her
sing live that [ __ ] is terrible it
changes your voice too like the actual
like the tone of your voice
and the pitch of your voice too which is
why like i sound
a lot lower than i usually do
so yeah and then knowing that i had this
condition
um at the same time like i went to the
ent uh
earlier lap last year and it was very
liberating to know like
i actually had notes even though i was
really sad but at the same time like
okay at least i know what the problem is
yeah um
and just like with more rest i've been
i'm being more aware and conscious of
like how i use my voice
um it doesn't help sometimes when i
stream i stream on twitch by the way
twitch.tv um it doesn't help sometimes
like with
hours and hours of talking uh it can
take a toll
but um knowing that
what the problem is now specifically
because back then like i didn't know i
had
i didn't have nodes it was like it was
just like a
small vocal tear yeah and it just like
developed over
time because i was just i i minimized it
yeah
and so now that i know it's it's it's an
actual issue
and not just me oh man vocal tears suck
like i remember because i used to go to
these like
you know ridiculous parties and [ __ ] and
we'd just be screaming yeah yeah and
then you could actually
when you're feeling it you could feel it
and i could actually taste blood
sometimes i'm like oh [ __ ] i think i
tore some [ __ ]
because we'd be screaming our [ __ ]
heads off and so like
i kind of i mean i healed from it so
it's fine but
i remember when that first happened i
was like i think i just tore my [ __ ]
you know oh no and then it sounds like
you had a good time though
yes we [ __ ] did yeah but that's why i
hate going to clubs too close you always
have to scream so you could talk to
somebody i avoid
very loud places yeah because that [ __ ]
[ __ ] your voice up all the time i don't
do that [ __ ] anymore it like ruins my
voice
it sucks and especially when i was doing
these [ __ ] youtube videos all i was
doing was screaming that [ __ ] sucked did
it ruin my voice
i [ __ ] hated it how does it help with
your
i mean i think mentally because your
whole life you have been singing and
that's something
that you know obviously you have found a
way to still be involved in music right
yes
but now that performance aspect is not
there and you know you do have these
vocal notes how does that how does that
make you feel
personally because i uh when i'm
thinking about that i think of
you know fighters who get really old you
know
they can't do what they what they feel
like is their kind of like their destiny
to do right and
sometimes these things happen identity
yeah it gets stripped away and then you
have to make adjustments some people
don't make great adjustments and
they kind of spiral so for you how do
you deal with that oh
so that that is actually like the
the the main theme of
my 20s actually uh so the past like
three years
i'm 24 now um as i turned 21 i realized
i it was like very up and down after i
left korea after i left the label
i did a show on nickelodeon and that was
a very heavily
music music demanding show we had like
40 plus songs
and i i was a main character so i sang
on everything and um during that show
like i
i felt like me again i was able to sing
and then before then i like got some
rest before starting the show
so like i said someone calling you fat
and telling you to give me yeah and it
was like a good
confidence booster like i got to do
something that i really wanted to do
like as a kid like i've always wanted to
be
on disney or nickelodeon and i i got
i got the job and so i did that and i
also like
made a decent amount of money and um was
able to take care of my family too and
so like
it was great and then after the show i
was
doing a lot of music independently
and then i came to a point where i
started well starting to deal with vocal
issues again
and it didn't get better it just kept
getting worse and worse and worse
and it started taking a toll on my
mental health because
i hold so much pride i think you might
not understand like as a musician like
i hold so much pride in the quality of
my performances yeah yeah yeah um my
music i'm
super super picky and i'm a
perfectionist
and i really want to make sure that i'm
always getting better
but when i see and hear myself
not improving and just slowly feel like
i'm getting worse
i i i don't even know like
how to even describe the feeling of how
like i started to like hate myself
and like i started to lose like my sense
of identity
because i really let music like define
me as a whole
yeah even though mainly acting is like
my biggest passion but i've
held so much pride for my music because
i invested
so much of my life to it yeah um
and so so how do you deal with that then
i just
i don't know during that time
um i was just kind of living life
i think i just tried to distract myself
with other aspects of life like
i dated and like um
for the like being 20 like i never
really had a social life before
so i started like going out meeting
friends actual people my age
because like growing up when i was like
15 16 like everyone was always older
than me or i just like didn't have
friends at all
because i was constantly working and um
also i was a soloist it's not like i had
members
you know to like be friends with and so
um
yeah i just like
started living life and that's how i
coped with a lot of things like having
friends
um i still kept a really good
relationship with my mom
and doing music i think i just kind of
like
i just stuck it through i just thought
like i know i just kept thinking
it's gonna get better it's gonna get
better um
until i did it it got a lot worse now
um but i actually have been starting to
meditate
and it's been helping a lot i'm not
like a super religious person but i am
spiritual and i
like believe that there's something out
there like like a god or
some kind of like i know entity in the
universe and so
um mainly i just want to focus on like
centering myself
and um staying grounded and also just
getting back that like self love and
confidence that i had when i was
13. have you have you have you been
going to like therapy
or i i have gone to therapy but
um i i guess maybe because i haven't
found the right person yet
it hasn't really worked it takes so it
takes a while like yeah you know i think
the biggest misconception in therapy is
that
you think that the first therapist that
you go to is going to be the one it's
never like that that's just like finding
a church
you you cycle through a lot until you
find that person that really kind of you
can connect to and really open
yeah open with i've gone to three
different people and had multiple
sessions with them
but i just haven't found the right and
then corona hit
yeah such people with social anxiety
that should [ __ ] sucks
yeah but um i mean i'm
i've been very very aware of like my
mental health that i knew that i
accepted that it wasn't in the best
place
and so i'm just doing whatever it takes
to just really take care of myself
whether that's like meditation and i am
looking to see
um like online therapy as well
um but i just there's something about
like in person
yeah i mean you'll find out what works
for you and this is a
very interesting conversation just
because uh
you know i've i've had to have these
conversations with a lot of people
um specifically in this space when it
came to youtube
uh recently like i mentioned to you a
buddy of ours was talking about um
he tweeted out that his youtube isn't
doing as well as it used to
and he's kind of sad that he's accrued
so many subscribers
but you know only he's maybe getting
like a thousand views per video
right that's so unfortunate i feel that
the the harsh reality of things
especially
specifically when it comes to
entertainment and this is what i always
tell
a lot of my youtube friends and they
kind of get sad about
how their youtube views are or how their
career is going now
and some of these people they've been on
the space for ten plus years yeah and
what i tell them is that
you know television shows don't go past
barely past two three seasons
and you've been able to do what you've
been able to do with the amount of money
that you've made and accrued
whether you chose a waste at all was
your your choice you know but with all
that stuff that you've done
you've been able to basically have a
television show for 10 plus years
most people don't get that opportunity
right
very true like saying it like that wow
that's very eye-opening
it's kind of nuts like people i don't
think that really
sits well with people they don't really
think about that you've essentially been
able to develop your own television show
your own programming at your own accord
without having to go through any red
tape no producers nobody telling you how
to do things
forever and 10 plus years of it that's
[ __ ] crazy nobody gets that even some
of the most highly successful people on
youtube now
they're here for five years six years
they go nuts and they [ __ ] bounce
wow you know that's actually so true
well
i feel so much better it feels it's a
very crazy concept and when i you know
when i hear that and i see that i always
say too
there's a little bit of personal
responsibility for us too things change
taste change yeah if we're doing the
same thing over
and over and over and expecting better
results than the initial ones that we
got then
we're the ones that are insane at this
point if the platform has changed and
it's not being conducive to the stuff
that you like
then you either change and move with the
platform or you decide to do
something else when i decided to do
podcasting it was something that a lot
of these subscribers hated i lost like
half a million subscribers
like they just weren't on board they're
like we want you to do your rants or
whatever
and i explained to everybody else i
didn't explain i just kind of did it out
of nowhere
i [ __ ] up my bad guys but what
happened was that this platform
wasn't allowing somebody like me who's
very
uh opinionated curses a lot says a lot
of crazy [ __ ]
to monetize and they also wouldn't post
my videos anywhere because it's so
controversial
because it's not kid-friendly content
because
family-friendly you know i mean i don't
got blue eyes and [ __ ] blonde hair
not that
bro though anyways but you know i don't
i don't have these things that google
finds
very uh marketable and also profitable
so i saw this trend and i'm like well
either i can do something where i can
change my whole content change who i am
and still succeed on this because even
before this whole thing happened
my views were still getting 100 000
views 200 000 views it was still
decent right it wasn't like half a
million to a million than it was before
but a quarter million views per video
still not [ __ ] bad yeah
that's great so but what they didn't
also realize is that i didn't make a
single cent off
any of those videos for almost like two
years because
so on average and i'll give you guys
these metrics when i was making about
two videos per week
doing whatever the [ __ ] i want enjoying
it too i was averaging
maybe about 15 to 18 000 a month right
and this is just two videos a week
right averaging about 200 000 views per
video um because the ads were doing well
and the adpocalypse had
happened and i started doing more videos
per week
averaging more views more watch time
everything else and then my paycheck
went down to about
uh 1900 a month so holy
there there's this understanding that
people don't get they go you should do
these videos we love watching it i gotta
pay bills
like i can't i enjoy doing those videos
to a certain extent
yeah but nineteen hundred dollars a
month isn't gonna keep my [ __ ] bills
on no
period it's a lot of work it's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] ton of work yeah
it's not like i'm walking around
vlogging and not doing stuff with it
like i put a lot of effort into my
videos and people noticing because
people miss the sketches it's like
that's why they love it
yeah they're like you missed the
sketches those sketches cost [ __ ]
money like when i shoot one of those
videos those 900
are gone so what the [ __ ] so if i'm
making about 18 000 i'm spending about 5
000 to my production
i'm okay with that maybe even six
thousand yeah but uh after a while the
platform changed a lot and i had to make
a choice so when i switched over to
podcasting
it was something that i was like number
one i enjoy doing number two i love
talking to people number three i love
hearing stories so
i'm gonna switch to podcasting and i'm
gonna see what happens and that was
doing really well on the audio side
yeah so you know for you know somebody
like that like my friend like i want to
tell them like
you have to make those personal choices
to make these adjustments for yourself
you can't keep beating the same [ __ ]
drum and expecting a different tune
so times change times change a lot and
it's hard to tell older people that
sometimes right
because we we like to kind of sit in
what we want to do
and when it doesn't become successful we
look at everybody else specifically the
youth and say oh the youth doesn't know
what
what the [ __ ] is dope or whatever but
there was a time when we were younger
and we said the same thing about the
older generation
so either you don't want to do it
so if you don't want to do it that's
perfectly fine but you can't get mad at
people for not enjoying something
that they've seen for 10 years over and
over and over
even i'm gonna get tired of that [ __ ]
yeah you know and if you know some
people want me to go back to my old
content which i can
which i feel like rant and you know
verbal comedy doesn't really die out
it's still something that's very
current it's very political and you
could always talk about recent events
and everything
exactly but that [ __ ] becomes exhausting
screaming to a [ __ ] camera
24 7 is exhausting i can imagine and
also not good for your voice
it's not good for your voice it's not
good for your mental health to be angry
that all the time either that's so true
like and that's what happens like as i
got older i became more chill so it's
like
i'm i'm i'm watching this this stuff
that's happening and except for recently
the blm stuff which people are like oh
the old davidson's back and then i
stopped doing the videos
and they're like oh where'd they go it's
like i can't be angry all the time
like this is hard like i'm i got to
worry about my mental health i gotta be
happy a little more and if i'm not
really passionate or angry about
specific things
yeah it's like i can't i can't fake the
funk
it's it's never been like that for me oh
yeah so you know the space has changed a
lot i mean
so you know just to go back to what i
was saying it's like it's it's hard to
tell some people that not to really
define who they are within their career
because your career will change all the
time some people are very fortunate to
be able to kind of do what they want to
do and have it for the rest of their
life
and you know people have asked me what's
going to happen if youtube disappears i
was like i don't [ __ ] care
like i'll figure it out yeah like my
life isn't defined by my [ __ ] career
my career is just a small part of my
life like everything else in this world
there's so much this world has to
[ __ ] offer if i
disappeared right nobody knew who i was
tomorrow i could give a
[ __ ] less like i really could [ __ ]
care less
right now this podcast is great because
i get to reconnect to my fans
uh i love the people that watch this and
this is what i enjoy a lot right
going out doing these shows conversing
with people but if tomorrow god comes
down and goes david you can't do this
anymore i'm going to take this away from
you
i'd be like cool thank you for letting
me have it for this long i'm going to
adjust
and i got to do something else because
defining yourself in something that's
fleeting is the worst thing that you can
do
yeah fighters do that [ __ ] all the time
people who live in the spotlight
and they feed off of other people's
energy from that that type of [ __ ]
that [ __ ] all goes away yeah it goes
away eventually
except for maybe some of those few huge
stars out there
but at the end of the day for me if i
could find a duffel bag full of money
like like a gajillion dollars i still do
the podcast
but i take off all the [ __ ] ads i
wouldn't do any of that [ __ ] and i would
just continue doing what i'm doing
whether it made money or not that's a
dream yeah isn't that the dream
yeah it's like some people would ask
like if you made all this money what
would you do i was like i'd still be
doing the same thing
same i totally agree you know yeah which
is why like
also uh throughout the times like even
though
with youtube i felt a little discouraged
myself as well
yeah because you know the music scene
has died a lot
throughout the years um i i still
had passion for like making content and
because also i
struggle with my voice it is physically
hard
to sing every week different songs
and things like that and doing original
music i
also knew that i had a passion for video
games and that's why i discovered twitch
yeah i started streaming and i knew that
that was like a very big upcoming
platform
and so like it definitely helped to like
move with the times within that aspect
and then of course
i jumped the tick tock by train as well
and um i think it definitely helped that
i started
in the scene very early so i'm able to
catch on with the times pretty quick
but um yeah you made a really really
good point and i feel like people
that are in the scene listening to the
podcast can definitely take something
tick-tock is hard for me to hop on man
like i was like
i didn't ticked off for a hot second i
was like i can't do this [ __ ] i don't
think it yeah it's not for everyone it's
like i i tried liking it and i was like
i can't like this
it's tick tock is just like vying for me
i never liked vine so yeah like
it's hard for me to like tic tacs was
very short-lived oh very short-lived
and tick-tock too they kind of sell all
your information and [ __ ] you know the
whole i know i don't know what's
happening with that that [ __ ] is [ __ ]
scary
it's it's i mean who knows i mean that
shit's very it's very real so like
i'm okay off of that type of stuff um so
i decided not to do it but i still enjoy
tick tocks though i like watching that
[ __ ] especially when it comes to my
memes yeah so i get to watch the best
tick tocks when it becomes poppin
so i don't know the compilations exactly
that [ __ ] makes me [ __ ] die laughing
but yeah
they talk so weird though because you'll
i'll i'll see people they go oh i have
like i don't know 200
000 followers but those followers aren't
representative
of the views that they get in terms of
their videos like some of their videos
will get like
700 views and the next one will get 30
000 and yeah
very up and down yeah get like a hundred
views i'm like what the [ __ ] what's
what's the point of these followers like
what did they they
literally don't do anything the
algorithm is weird
yeah yeah like you don't get notified
when uh
a person that you follow posts a new
tech talk it's just like
some like facebook like you just keep
scrolling scrolling and scrolling
that content part's a little weird like
i i like to be a little more selective
instead of having to fish and scroll
through a gajillion things
but i think that's um that's a
preference that's a taste thing
it is yeah it's just the platform itself
yeah there's a lot of different apps
coming out like
my buddy david choi he's i mean you met
with him but you know david choi's
coming out this app called taco which is
going to be
pretty good for that yeah i mean it's a
social media platform that i think is
going to
do really well like i'm behind it i
think it's really dope me too
yeah it's gonna be fun for a lot of
people now with tech talk out of the way
i'm definitely gonna jump on that so
what's what's your what's your next move
i mean you've you've gone through
a whole [ __ ] ton of trials and
tribulations and now you're 24.
so so what's your next move now um like
career-wise or career-wise everything
love life whatever what you're thinking
about so um
definitely did a lot of thinking during
this pandemic you know i
i moved into my own apartment uh in
january
and i have a dog now so definitely
living the fullest adult life
learning a lot about myself um i still i
still live really
really really close to my my mom okay my
family
um so i still get to see them very often
and but still have like my own spacing
gnomes yeah yeah
um yeah like i think my next moves
honestly
i i think i was like kind of going
through like an early quarter life
crisis
uh the past two years two three years
and now i just really wanna like
enjoy the journey of uh learning to
accept myself for who i am and all of my
my past trials and tribulations um
that's my biggest goal just to like
yeah find peace mm-hmm um who
do you do you have any like close
friends by that you kick it with and
yeah well that's good i have a few um
been very very lucky
and yeah like i've always been very
surround
surrounded with really good people
that's definitely something i've been
blessed with all my life
and very very thankful for that um
but like career-wise like i do stream on
twitch and
um i been i've been writing for
korean artists so like i'm still in that
industry but more behind the scenes so
it's like
real chill and i just get the paychecks
rolling yeah
like yeah i i like this
yeah yeah um so yeah like i i still do
music
um and i think i i have a lot of fun
with it because i love songwriting
and it's a passion that i developed uh
since i was like 14 years old
and definitely tapped into that artistry
while i was in korea
actually because like going through all
that live [ __ ]
i was able to really find my outlet to
express myself
through writing yeah and so um
definitely carried over the years and
worked on my craft
real hard and now i'm like i have some
pretty cool artists up my sleeves that
i've written for
um and so i'm just continuing to do that
having the next single next huge k-pop
star
singing my song that's just like my my
main goal and then like of course acting
but like
kind of on pause right now that's the
that's just from the uh the pandemic
going on right now
so acting is one of those things um yeah
i feel like i feel like acting is
one of those that's just so [ __ ] hard
man like i
to get into like the mindset of an actor
like you have to really [ __ ] love
this [ __ ] man
like acting is something you really have
to love for
for the opportunity to do something that
you may like
the chance that you'll pop off and make
a good jillion dollars off of that [ __ ]
it's
[ __ ] slim to none yeah it's a very
small [ __ ] handful it really is
and you know you're like oh you have a
lot of friends who are on tv shows
yeah but they're not rich
there's a reason why we're called
struggling actors yeah like just could
you see somebody on a tv show unless
they're like uh
on a really popular tv show and they're
series regulars
it's it's not like that you know and how
many tv shows can you name off the top
of your head that you really really
enjoy that's going on right now
and how many slots are there yeah you
know and i think like
that that whole acting aspect is just so
difficult because
it's like being criticized or not even
criticized it's like you don't know what
the [ __ ] you're [ __ ] up on and you
get no feedback and you walk out
yeah oh my gosh i was like figure it out
i'm like
oh [ __ ] you know and you have to figure
it out with your
with your acting coaches and it's um
like i
had a mystery yeah all the time i had a
conversation with this guy named jesse
and uh he's in narcos and
came on the podcast and we had a dope
conversation and he was kind of telling
me about the outlook the
outlook of acting and kind of being able
to kind of put your own spin and taste
of stuff that
sometimes it makes it feel like you
don't have a lot of control of these
things right
depending on the roles that you're going
on but you know acting is such a grind
and it's such a process that
there are people who do it for 30 40
years and they never pop off and they
still continue to do it because they
love it so much
that's that's true dedication right
there honestly i don't know i got that
i can't do that like i can't do that
[ __ ] at all like i enjoy
acting if it's something very particular
that i really really [ __ ] like for
sure
but if it's me having to go on these
auditions like i don't mind auditions
then
i don't they don't scare me anymore i
just go in and i see what the [ __ ]
happens
yeah but um the the hard part about it
is just like
i dread it a lot because i don't like it
and i think that's like the the bigger
realization for me was when i was going
to these auditions i was like okay i was
scared for the first two
after the first two it's just scabbed
over i just go in in out in out and out
call back call back call back call back
and you don't get it it's like what the
[ __ ] is with these [ __ ] calls oh my
gosh yeah i mean stop calling me [ __ ]
back i'm just going to give you this
so hard and then you get pinned and
you're like wait i think i have a chance
getting this
like don't even [ __ ] pin me like just
tell me yes or no
i don't want to hear any of this [ __ ]
yes or no yeah like i've had some
it kind of like brings your hope up and
then they [ __ ] crush you
oh man that's why we have the thickest
skin for sure
yeah you just kind of gotta smile with
it and move on i mean yeah i think
honestly it's like i've kind of learned
to just enjoy the process like
and just not really expect anything i
mean it's really hard
i still struggle with it a lot but
that's why we have like other outlets of
creativity that we can
like i don't know how actors just only
do acting and they have like their
their day job like i don't know how they
do that um
because like i need to do other things
to keep myself busy and my
mind off of like the audition i just
went on it's hard man just kind of
i don't i don't understand how
i mean i do get it but there's only been
i think like every time i went on
audition there was only one thing that i
liked out of the whole year when i was
going back to back to back to back
auditions for all these series regular
stuff
yeah i only liked one script and i
somehow had to pretend i had like
80 of these things 80 or 90 of these
things and i'm like it happens a lot
there's just so much content out there
and now that with like you know new
media and all that stuff
yeah and it was hard for me i think
that's the reason why i know that i'm
not an actor's actor is because i've had
the opportunity to do things that i
enjoyed
but then when it came to stuff that i
had to act and that i was fighting for a
role that
for a role i didn't care about it was
super hard because i feel like sometimes
for an actor there's just i just want to
book anything
and i just want to perform i don't have
that i just i want to perform stuff and
act and stuff that i actually give a
[ __ ] about
so it's very difficult so it's like any
that's why i enjoy indie films a lot
like if there's an indie film there's a
script that i like and i enjoy i'll do
what i whatever i can to be in it it's
not going to pay much
but i i like that and that's the heart
the heart of the content
yeah sounds very difficult okay well
guys
that wraps up this episode of the genius
brain podcast megan where can they find
you
you can find me at hello megan lee on
instagram youtube
twitter twitch tick tock
everything soon taco i know so wait so
you've gotten your
handle on everything pretty much yeah
how this you have such a common [ __ ]
name what the hell
that's nuts i have my ways that's nice
you're so [ __ ] lucky well guys you
can catch the genius brain podcast every
thursdays and sundays and we will see
you all next time
peace thanks for having me cool